Salut ! On dit souvent qu'il faut se
concentrer sur une chose pour bien la faire,
mais peut-on faire plusieurs
choses en même temps ?
Aujourd'hui, je vais vous parler
du mode multitâche du cerveau.
Je vais également mentaliser
une personne, ça fait longtemps...
Et vous donner des conseils pour
gérer plusieurs actions en même temps.
Et aujourd'hui, il y aura un bonus
à la fin de la vidéo.
Gérénique.
[Musique du Générique]
Il ne faut pas confondre
le fait de faire plusieurs
choses en même temps
avec l'attention.
Même s'il existent certains
ponts entre les deux.
La concentration sur un point précis
permet, justement de duper le cerveau,
comme dans la vidéo où
je vous avais mis au défi,
vous pouvez la voir : ici !
Et d'ailleurs vous venez juste
de le vivre à l'instant.
Je sais. Je vous entends
dire dans les commentaires...
Vous avez cru voir
quelque chose bouger.
Juste là.
Derrière moi.
Mais c'est peut-être un simple
détournement d'attention
qui vous a empêché de voir...
ben, que j'avais changé de T-Shirt...
Oui.
Vous pouvez vérifier.
De base, on sait très bien faire
deux choses en même temps.
Discuter en regardant
ses réseaux sociaux,
mettre un like en
regardant une vidéo...
Hein... ?   Quoi... ?
Ça... ça s'est vu
peut-être ?
Ou encore, téléphoner
en conduisant.
Et ça c'est
une belle connerie !
Pour rappel, une étude a prouvé
que téléphoner en conduisant
augmente le risque
d'accident mortel
par un multiplicateur de 5 !
Nous savons traiter plusieurs
informations en même temps.
Mais, est-ce qu'on peut
vraiment être efficace ?
Peut-on s'entraîner
pour s'améliorer ?
On va faire un jeu ensemble,
c'est le test de Stroop.
Il va vous faire ressentir
l'effet Stroop,
qui a été démontré par
un mec qui s'eppelle
John Ridley Stroop
C'est bien foutu.
En 1935.
Dans la revue :
Journal of experimental psychology.
Vous devez absolument
faire ça à voix haute
ou alors en chuchotant,
mais verbalisez bien
chaque étape.
Vous allez passer pour quelqu'un
de chelou !
C'est sûr !
Tu parles à qui ?
A Stroop...
Ah oui, d'accord...
Et vous devez faire ce test
le plus rapidement possible,
c'est très simple.
Pour la première phase, vous allez lire,
le plus rapidement possible,
les mots qu'il y a écrit
dans ce tableau...
Vous lisez les mots
tel qu'ils sont écrits.
Allez-y, je vous laisse quelques
secondes pour le faire.
[Musique d'attente]
Deuxième phase, vous allez dire maintenant,
le plus rapidement possible toujours,
les couleurs de chaque cadre.
Donc, le plus vite possible,
allez-y. Je vous laisse quelques
secondes pour le faire également.
[Musique]
Et enfin, maintenant, vous allez me dire
de quelle couleur sont écrits les mots.
Donc, pas les mots en eux-mêmes
mais de quelle couleurs ils sont écrits.
Et vous devez faire ça aussi
le plus rapidement possible,
Allez-y !
Je vous laisse encore quelques
secondes pour le faire.
[Musique]
Vous avez vu ? Elle n'est pas
si simple la dernière phase.
Plus c'est compliqué pour vous,
plus ça signifie que vous avez
une très bonne lecture automatique
par votre cerveau.
L'effet Stroop, par exemple,
est très faible, voire nul,
chez les enfants qui viennent
juste d'apprendre à lire.
La difficulté de la 3ème phase
vient d'une interférence entre
un traitement cognitif SUR un autre.
Ce qui est intéressant c'est donc
qu'avant même de faire 2 choses en même temps,
notre cerveau semble parasité
par les tâches qu'on lui a automatisées.
Qu'on lui a programmées.
Je vous mets, dans la description,
un lien vers les planches de Stroop,
si jamais vous voulez les enregistrer
dans votre téléphone, par exemple,
pour le faire sur quelqu'un.
Avec le résumé des étapes.
Frédéric Paulhan,
un phylopsophe français,
a publié un article en 1887...
sur la simultanéité
des actes psychiques.
Alors, il a fait plein de recherches
pour ça, il a expérimenté plein de trucs,
par exemple : il écrivait du Racine
tout en écrivant du Victor Hugo...
Il a fait plein de tests comme ça
et, à la fin, il a isolé
deux choses très intéressantes :
Premièrement, la résolution de
chacune des deux tâches
est plus longue qu'à la normale
et il y a plus d'erreurs
qu'à la normale.
La deuxième chose, c'est que
la durée totale de l'exécution des 2 tâches,
en simultanée
est très inférieure à la somme des durées de
chaque tâche qui aurait été faite de manière isolée.
Depuis, de nombreux travaux ont été faits
de nombreuses études ont été réalisées,
mais à notre époque, clairement,
tout va plus vite.
Le temps, c'est un peu devenu
une donnée précieuse.
Vous savez, comme dans le film
"Time Out".
On s'éparpille assez vite,
et on ne conçoit pas de faire
qu'une seule chose à la fois.
Ce n'est même plus dans nos codes,
en fait, d'être monotâche.
J'ai un exemple très concret.
Et j'aimerais bien que vous soyez
vraiment sincères.
Qu'est-ce que vous, là, maintenant,
tout de suite, vous êtes en train de faire
en plus de regarder cette vidéo ?
Alors, oui...
Je me doute que certains
sont aux toilettes...
Si c'est le cas, un simple
double hashtag #PasSilencieux #EtPourCause
fera bien l'affaire dans les commentaires...
Je veux pas les détails !
Mais les autres, vous êtes en train
de faire quelque chose,
peut-être en train de regarder la télé...
ou d'écouter quelqu'un parler...
En tout cas, ce que je sais,
c'est que la majorité d'entre vous
sont en train de cumuler deux actions
en même temps.
Bon, on commence à répondre
à la question :
Donc, oui, on peut faire
plusieurs choses en même temps,
mais on détériore la qualité
de ces 2 actions.
Puisque, à chaque fois,
il y a un conflit cognitif.
Alors, l'idée que j'ai eue, c'est ce que
je vous ai annoncé au début de la vidéo,
c'est de voir si je pouvais profiter
de ce conflit cognitif
pour mentaliser une personne.
Comme vous pouvez le voir, je suis dans
les loges du théâtre de Senas
où je fais mon spectacle aujourd'hui.
Donc, je vais aller mentaliser
le régisseur du théâtre.
[Fab] Donc, tu connais un peu l'univers
Youtube, et ça c'est parfait.
J'ai besoin que tu choisisses un Youtubeur
ou un nom de chaîne de Youtubeur...
C'est peut-être plus simple ?
[Fab] C'est ça ?
[Guillaume] Ouais.
[Fab]Alors : un nom de chaîne de Youtubeur
dans ta tête. Je ne peux pas connaître ça.
Tu me dis quand tu es prêt.
[Gui] C'est bon pour moi.
[Fab] Guillaume, c'est le régisseur de
mon spectacle, ce soir à Senas.
L'idée est la suivante :
c'est que je vais te faire
faire une action
et, en même temps, je vais te poser
des questions sur ce Youtubeur.
Sauf que...
Tu vas pouvoir me dire la vérité
ou me mentir à chaque fois.
Tu vois ?
A chaque coup, tu peux changer :
mentir ou dire la vérité.
Mais en même temps,
tu vas faire un calcul...
Un calcul à main levée.
Euh... ta date de naissance c'est ?
[Gui] Le 26 mars...
[Fab] Le 26 mars.
[Gui] 82
[Fab] 1982.
[Fab] Et ton département de naissance ?
[Gui] 84.
[Fab]84.  Et dis moi un chiffre
entre 2 et 9.
[Gui] Euh... 7.
[Fab] 7 ...  fois  ...  7
[Gui] C'est ce que ....( inaudible )
[Fab] Ok.
[Fab]Tu vas résoudre cette multiplication.
Tout en me parlant.
Ne t'inquiètes pas si tu fais
des erreurs, ce n'est pas très grave,
quand on fait 2 tâches en même temps,  justement,
on a vu qu'on faisait souvent des erreurs.
[Gui - Approuvant]  Hmm  hmm
[Fab] Donc, il n'y a pas de soucis.
[Fab] J'ai envie d'illustrer quelque chose
pour cette vidéo.
Donc, vas-y, commence à faire
ton calcul...
Et je vais te poser, donc, des questions
sur le Youtubeur
et, à chaque fois, tu peux
me mentir ou me dire la vérité.
[Fab] Voilà.
[Gui]Faut vraiment qu'on...
[Fab]Ouais ! C'est compliqué, hein !?
[Fab] C'est pas si simple.
[Fab]C'est un homme ?
[Gui] Tout à fait.
[Fab]Ok
[Fab] Et, euh... sur Youtube,
il fait du gaming ?
[Gui]Pas du tout !
[Gui] Je peux mentir.
[Fab]Tu peux mentir ou dire la vérité,
tu fais tout ce que tu veux.
[Gui - A lui-même] Je me suis
peut-être gouré là...
[Fab] Et euh... sinon, euh... il fait des...
vidéos de beauté ?
[Gui] Euh... je peux mentir, dire la vérité...
[Fab] Tu dis toujours ce que tu veux.
[Gui] Il ne fait pas de vidéos de beauté.
[Fab]D'accord.
[Fab]C'est bien d'essayer de
m'embrouiller en même temps.
[Fab] Pas mal, hein ?
[Gui]Un petit côté pervers...
[Fab] Il fait de la vulgarisation scientifique ?
[Gui] Pas du tout !
[Fab] Pas du tout... non. Ok.
[Fab] Vas-y. Continue à calculer,
c'est important.
[Fab] C'est important.
[Fab] C'est quelqu'un de très connu
sut Youtube ? Ou c'est euh...
[Fab] C'est à dire : qui a passé le million
d'abonnés, d'après toi, ou pas ?
[Gui] Je pense, ouais.
[Fab] Tu penses.
[Fab] Et il fait une vidéo tous les jours !
[Fab] Quasiment, quoi.
[Gui] Euh......... ouais.
[Gui] Voire même, des fois,
plusieurs par jour.
[Fab] Ah ouais. Plusieurs par jour...
Mille par jour, même, j'suis sûr...
[Fab] Des f...
ça a dû arriver.
[Fab]Ouais. C'est ça...
[Gui] Il est allé jusque là...
[Gui] Tu vois qui c'est ?
[Fab] Ouais, je vois qui c'est, c'est sûr.
[Gui] Je confirme, c'est complétement compliqué
[Gui] tout ça. Mais je vais jusqu'au bout.
[Fab] C'est dur hein ? Il faut aller jusqu'au bout.
[Gui] Alors euh...
[Fab] Et tout en parlant et en prenant
la décision de mentir ou pas quoi, hein...
[Fab] Et euh...
[Gui - A lui-même]Ah, j'suis bien là
[Fab] Et euh...  Est-ce que...
Est-ce que c'est une euh...
Une vieille chaîne, entre guillemets,
qui a plus de trois ans ?
[Gui]Oui.
[Fab] D'accord.     Ok.
[Fab] Et euh....
[Fab] Et c'est quelqu'un que
tu aimerais rencontrer ?
[Gui] Ouais.
[Gui] Ouais, ouais.
[Son accéléré incompréhensible]
[Fab] C'est une chaîne aussi qui est
un peu virale, sur Facebook et tout ça, ou pas du tout ?
[Gui]  Ouais ...[incompréhensible]...  Mais après,
Facebook, chacun a le mur qu'il mérite...
[Fab] Ouais.   Non, mais c'est vrai.
[Fab] Et euh...
[Gui] Est-ce que je fais une vérif ?
[Fab] Ouais, vérifie en même temps, ouais.
Fais deux actions en même temps,
mais moi je pense avoir ta chaîne.
Je dirais, par déduction, par rapport à tout
ce que tu m'as dit, tout ce que j'ai cherché, etc...
Je pense que c'est la chaîne
de Osons Causer.
[Gui]C'est absolument ça.
[Fab] C'est ça ? Et ça c'est la vérité ?
[Gui] Oui, c'est la vérité.
[Fab] Oui !
[Fab] Je remercie Guillaume donc,
qui est le régisseur ce soir,
tu n'étais pas complice de
quoi que ce soit.
Mais grâce à toi, on a pu symboliser
ce dont je vous parle depuis le début de la vidéo,
et on va continuer maintenant, avec les conseils,
pour aller un peu plus dans ce sens.
A savoir : qu'est-ce qui se passe
quand on fait du multitâche ?
Vous avez pu voir, et je pense que vous
avez eu les mêmes pistes que moi,
à quel point c'était compliqué, pour lui,
de mentir en réalisant ce calcul.
Et ce conflit cognitif m'a permis de voir,
mais très clairement !
quand est-ce qu'il mentait.
Et je pense que vous aussi
vous avez vu ça.
Vous pouvez maintenant,
avec cette donnée là,
essayer de revoir la vidéo,
maintenant que vous savez
qu'il pensait à Osons Causer.
Et, pour la petite histoire,
j'ai commencé cette vidéo
d'abord en le mentalisant.
Même si je ne vous l'ai mis
que maintenant.
En tout cas, ça m'a permis
d'affiner ma recherche
en ayant ces infos là
sur le mensonge.
Et ça me permettait d'aller,
de manière plus "safe",
et plus simple que d'autres méthodes,
vers la déduction finale,
puisque, après, j'ai appliqué un effet tunnel
du stock reading,
et puis mes autres popotes de mentaliste
dont on a déjà parlé sur cette chaîne.
C'était la vidéo pour le prénom,
d'ailleurs je vous la remets ici.
Maintenant, les conseils, pour pouvoir
s'optimiser en faisant du multitâche...
Alors, déjà, il faut savoir qu'il y a une étude
qui a été publiée dans Neuron en 2015,
je vous mets le lien dans la description,
sur la gestions multitâche de notre cerveau
et qui tend à démontrer que,
contrairement à ce qu'on croyait,
que les ressources cognitives de notre cerveau
ne sont pas partagées quand on est en multitâche,
mais qu'elles ne s'altèrent pas
non plus.
La réalité serait à mi-chemin
entre les deux.
Et les chercheurs sont encore aujourd'hui,
en 2017, en train d'étudier ce phénomène.
J'ai remarqué, ça c'est juste
un avis personnel d'expérience, que
quand les 2 tâches, qu'on doit réaliser
en même temps, sont similaires,
c'est plus facile de le faire.
Vous pouvez, par exemple,
en discutant avec quelqu'un,
vous concentrer sur une discussion
qui est à côté.
C'est à dire : écouter l'autre discussion
et écouter ce que la personne vous dit,
et lui répondre.
Si votre discussion à vous, personnelle,
n'est pas trop gourmande intellectuellement,
vous devriez être capable
de suivre les 2 en même temps.
Je vous conseille d'essayer ça
dans un premier temps.
Mais, le meilleur des conseils,
et je ne savais pas que cette vidéo
allait aboutir à celui-ci,
après toutes les études que j'ai lues,
après toutes les recherches
que j'ai faites,
c'est qu'il vaut mieux gérer les choses
les unes après les autres.
Une par une.
Mais, par contre, en alternant souvent !
C'est à dire : faire un petit peu d'une tâche,
un petit peu d'une autre, un petit peu d'une autre,
revenir sur celle-ci, sur celle-ci,
sur celle-ci...
Le mieux c'est encore de créer
des Todo-listes,
et de s'organiser efficacement.
Abonnez-vous à la chaîne et
likez la si la vidéo vous a plu.
"Pas silencieux", je compte sur vous.
C'était ridicule...
Et il y a un bonus.
En regardant la vidéo plus attentivement,
vous allez trouver une énigme
à résoudre à l'intérieur.
Cette énigme vous donnera de l'avance
pour quelque chose concernant un trophée...
Si vous avez vu cette vidéo,
par exemple...
Ça devrait vous parler.
A très bientôt.
Ciao !
[Musique du générique de fin]